talk more about the implications of the
Cohen plea with Catherine here and also
joining us from New York Fox News senior
judicial analyst Judge Andrew Napolitano
judge you hear the president he says
listen I was a businessman I was running
for president I could do this the deal
never came around it didn't it didn't
materialize where is the threat to the
president in this particular development
today
well the statements that the president
made which which you just summarized are
all probably true and they don't reflect
anything unlawful but the danger for him
is whatever Michael Cohen told Bob
Muller's investigators in the 70 hours
that they debriefed him sometime in the
past three or four months the last time
Michael Cohen pleaded guilty
the prosecuting entity was the federal
prosecutors here in New York in the same
courthouse today when he pleaded guilty
it was Bob Muller's team which came up
from Washington DC so we don't know what
Michael Cohen gave Bob Muller in return
for reducing his exposure from many
years in jail down to six months that's
the danger to the President and we may
never know it it depends how Bob Muller
wants to use it Michael Cohen is not
somebody that Bob Moe is gonna put on
the witness stand any more than he's
going to put Paul Manafort on the stand
but he can take the information they
gave him and if he can corroborate it
through a credible source use it
thereafter right and that's important
because Katherine to judge is point I
mean you you are losing credibility when
you charge somebody criminally with
lying he has done that numerous times
now so these people are not exactly the
best witnesses if you're bringing a case
forward but we don't know what else
Muller has to corroborate some of this
stuff we don't and the criticism of the
special counsel is that these are all
processed crimes these are lying to
federal investigators they are lying to
Congress I'm not in any way minimizing
that but it doesn't go to the core issue
of the allegation of coordination
between the Trump campaign
and Russian officials something that
really caught my attention today is that
people should be prosecuted for lying to
Congress but other individuals at the
heart of the Russia case such as
Christopher Steele who was the author of
the Trump dossier he is the subject of a
criminal referral from the Senate
Judiciary Committee also Glenn Simpson
of fusion GPS his firm was played by the
DNC in the Clinton campaign to put the
dossier together and he has a
problematic testimony to Congress so
publicly we haven't seen any action on
those cases maybe privately it's
happened but Cohen is really the first
person we see pay a penalty you know
judge it does seem like this is coming
to a head it also seems perhaps that
Muller or his team have concerns about
Matt Whittaker the acting Attorney
General and that maybe some of these
court filings are really about getting
the story as they see it out just in
case the report doesn't make it through
that block of Matt Whittaker at the
Justice Department well yeah well you're
right about that I mean in in examining
the Special Counsel rules it's
interesting the special counsel doesn't
need acting Attorney General Whitaker's
approval to do anything he merely must
inform acting Attorney General Whittaker
Matt Whittaker of whatever he's going to
do which we gather from the reporting of
our colleague John Roberts happened last
night at about the same time that the
that the White House learned about this
but but you're you're correct a lot of
things have happened since the midterm
elections and this has been a critical
week I don't think that we've seen the
end of this I described what happened in
court this morning as it's a it's a
trite phrase but I think it's accurate
here the tip of the iceberg Bob Muller
knows what the rest of that iceberg is
Michael Cohen knows what the rest of
that iceberg is Muller will decide when
how and under what circumstances - if at
all - let the rest of us know yeah it
does seem like everything went a little
bit more fast forward kathryn after the
president filed the answers to those
questions which you said included one
about this real estate deal I think that
was one of the big revelations today as
the special counsel Muller among those
questions did ask about this proposal to
build a tower in Moscow by the Trump
Organization up until now
that was certainly not known to us
through our reporting and what rudy
giuliani the president's attorney said
to us today is that they don't see any
contradiction between the president's
written answers and what was stated in
the Cohen plea so they still feel very
comfortable but the timing when you line
up the data points certainly has that
feel of almost a cascading or a domino
effect
you know judge we've seen all kinds of
reporting here there's new reporting
right now BuzzFeed has a story saying
that president Trump's company planned
to give a 50 million dollar penthouse at
Trump Tower Moscow to Vladimir Putin as
the company negotiated this luxury real
estate development during the 2016
campaign according to four people we
don't have that independently confirmed
we've seen other stories fall apart so
we'll be careful about this but is the
argument that a negotiation even if he's
doing a business deal that as that's
happening with a hostile foreign power
as he's running for president and
eventually becomes president that it is
potentially something that is could be
held over the head of the president by
Russia you know I think the president's
statement today he ran a clip of it
earlier when John Roberts was on in
which he said what's the big deal this
is a deal we didn't do I think he's on
very solid ground there the problem for
the president will come if for example
Michael Cohen says the president told me
to lie and I'd lied before the the
Senate Intelligence Committee because he
and I decided to concoct a scheme to
trick people that's where the president
will be impaled but not doing a deal no
matter how luxurious it was or or or
lurid it was not doing it can't hurt him
all right Catherine judge thank you very
much